Uh my name is Dinda and I'm uh security
uh
please go ahead.
Okay.
Islam.
The sister is asking her name is Dinda.
She is a security officer and she is
asking that in her religion Christianity
the they learn about trinity. There is
father there is son and there is holy
ghost. So she wants to know who is the
holy spirit in Islam.
Sister asked a good question that she
says that they believe in the trinity in
Christianity. She wants to know who is
the holy spirit in Islam. Sister
>> yes
>> in Christianity and Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> In Islam there is no trinity.
And do you know that the word trinity
doesn't exist anywhere in the Bible?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you mention where is the word
trinity mentioned in the Bible?
>> Yeah. translate.
>> Um
>> Oh, thanks.
>> Okay. Um I
>> Yeah. Uhinity.
But the trinity is mentioned in the
Quran.
She she says
>> she says trinity is in Bible but she's
she doesn't know the reference. There is
the word trinity doesn't exist in the
Bible. I'm a student of the Bible. I
challenge you to show the word trinity
anywhere in the Bible is not there but
it is there in the Quran.
Trinity doesn't exist anywhere in the
Bible.
Dr.
Quran
>> the word trinity doesn't exist anywhere
in the Bible but it exists in the Quran
Quran says in surah Nisa chapter 4 verse
number 171
do not say trinity it's mentioned in the
Quran the second place in surah maida
chapter number five
verse number 73
they are doing blasphemy those who say
that Trinity. But there is a verse in
the Bible which is close to trinity. The
word trinity doesn't exist in the Bible.
The concept of trinity that exist in the
Bible is first epistle of John chapter
number 5 verse number 7. For there are
three that bear record in heaven. The
father, the son and the holy spirit. And
these three are one. And this verse of
the Bible, if you read the revised
standard version of the Bible, revised
by Taidu scholars, Christian scholars of
the highest eminence, backed by 50
different corporate missions, they say
this verse of the Bible is
interpolation, is a fabrication, is a
concoction and they have thrown it out
of the Bible. So the closest verse the
word trinity doesn't exist any in the
bible but the verse which is closest to
the concept of trinity is first epistle
of John chapter number 5 verse number 7.
Now what you're talking about trinity is
not there in the bible it is the
teaching of the church
the church says that father is a person
the holy spirit is a person the son is a
person but they aren't three person but
they're one person. This is the teaching
of the church not of the Bible sister.
So you as a Christian should follow the
church of the Bible.
If you believe Bible is from God,
nowhere does the word trinity exist
anywhere in the Bible.
This is the teaching of the church that
father is a person. Son is a person.
Holy Spirit is a person. So in Islam we
don't believe in trinity. We believe in
O Israel the Lord our God is one Lord.
So we believe in what Jesus Christ peace
be upon him taught. When Jesus Christ
was asked peace be upon him when he was
asked in the gospel of Mark chapter
number 12 verse number 29 which is the
first of the commandment. He said
verbitum what Moses peace be upon him
said in Hebrew. Shama Israel,
the Lord, our God is one Lord. So the
concept of trinity is a teaching of the
church. It is not the teaching of the
Bible. So in Islam
it is said
do not say trinity.
Decess stop it. It's better for you. So
the word trinity is not there in the
Bible.
God is only one. So this concept
that God is a person, son is a person,
holy spirit is a person but they are
three person one person doesn't make
sense logically it makes any sense. I am
asking you the question when Jesus
Christ peace be upon according to the
false reading of the bible when he died
for 3 days. So did God die for 3 days?
>> Yes
>> God died
>> in Bible says uh
>> not in Bible it's teaching of the
church. Bible doesn't say God died. It
is the false teaching of the church of
the trinity.
Can God die?
Do you want to believe in a God which
can die or God which cannot die? In
Islam, God cannot die.
>> Yes, cannot die.
>> But in Christianity, God can die.
>> Christianity say
>> it is not Christianity is the teaching
of the church. Sister,
if you read the Bible correctly, today I
quoted the Bible correct.
So many verses.
If Christian means a person who follows
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him, then we Muslims are more
Christian than the Christian themselves.
Sister, do you believe Jesus Christ is a
messenger of God or God?
>> Jesus is a messenger of God.
>> Mashallah,
[Applause]
sister, do you believe that there's one
God?
>> Yeah. Do you believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of God?
>> Yes, I believe.
>> Then you're a Muslim. Mashallah.
There are two things required for anyone
to be a Muslim. Number one, believe
there's one God. Number two, believe
that Prophet Muhammad is a messenger of
God. And if you are a Christian and you
rightly said that Jesus is a messenger
of God, peace be upon him. We Muslims,
we respect Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, more than the Christians. See,
whenever I take the name of Jesus, I add
peace be upon him. Correct?
So I'm respecting him more than the
Christians right or wrong.
So since you believe there's one God,
since you believe that Prophet Muhammad
is a messenger of God, would you like to
accept Islam?
>> Yes.
>> Would you like to accept Islam?
Then ask also in Malay, is anyone
forcing you to accept Islam?
>> Yeah.
>> Islam.
>> Uh no.
>> Are you doing it of your own free will?
Yeah.
>> Okay. In I'll say in Arabic and you can
repeat it.
>> Ashu Allah.
>> Allahall
>> Ashua
>> Muhammad
>> Muhamadan
>> Abdu
>> Abdulu.
>> I bear witness
>> that there is no God
>> but Allah
>> but Allah. And prophet Muhammad
>> And prophet Muhammad
>> is the messenger
>> and servant
>> and
>> servant
>> of Allah
>> of Allah.
>> Mashallah you're a Muslim mir.
[Applause]
[Music]
>> Mashallah. May Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
reward you sister. All your previous
sins have been forgiven. I pray to Allah
that may he give you the best in this
world and the AK and I pray to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala that may you get
your friends and your family also to the
true path. Inshallah I'd request the
volunteers to be in touch with the
sister and if she has any questions any
difficulties please see to it that you
answer to her queries.